Aaron you you still you know you have a
daughter and I what's it like if you're
with your daughter first of all I'm
hoping the old [ __ ] is like maybe
tapering off a little bit not really no
no no I get I get called a [ __ ] every
day yeah I mean it used to be so many
times a day now it's like three to five
times now what's that like is from his
wife
I love you Dave wherever you are you you
have a as a little girl a little a
little five month old five month old
girl I mean how do you bail she's too
young now she's the best yeah
what how do you feel about the fact that
you might be walking around with your
child two three years from now and
people are gonna go yo [ __ ] at you call
you a [ __ ] in front of your daughter
how are you preparing for this I mean
I'm just afraid that it may be her first
word yeah he's gonna hear it so much
I'll be used to it yeah yeah I just have
to sit her down and explain it to her
yeah Shores show the show you know right
you really that's a good idea
you